hi good to see you thanks for joining us
um what are we making of what we're
hearing about the bank of England saying
they're not going to offer any more
support to pensions after Friday are we
worried I think it is worrying there's
obviously been a level of volatility
again in the markets and people are
obviously worried about the cost of
borrowing continuing to increase at
least of all mortgage payers who are
struggling with very high payments at
the moment so I think it is is clearly
worrying but all of this is a response
to the fact that the bank of England has
had to step in three times now to try
and stabilize the markets after the mini
budget the quickest and simplest way to
deal with this is for this government
that has crashed the economy and loaded
the costs onto working people to reverse
the mini budget and provide some calm
and stability in the markets again
yesterday I spoke to the Deputy Prime
Minister she said that the economy was
on track
um and then I spoke to the business
secretary today and he says there's
nothing to worry about yeah I mean we've
got the spectacle of a business
secretary touring the TV studios this
morning trying to convince people that
Pension funds are safe this is a really
serious situation and a very bad
situation for the government to have got
themselves into this is a crisis that
was made in Downing Street it was a
deliberate decision to announce 43
billion pounds worth of unfunded
commitments not to publish an
independent assessment alongside that as
is normally the case it spooked the
markets it's pushed borrowing costs up
it's had a major impact on families
across the country and businesses
particularly mortgage payers who've seen
their mortgages Rise by an average of
500 pounds every month as they come off
fix their mortgages the government needs
to go back to the drawing board
urgently and start again but the
business secretary is saying as far as
Pension funds are concerned they're safe
as houses feel forgive upon but if they
do go under because they're taking to a
higher risk well it
all of this is caused by the government
and there's every attempt that I've seen
on your showcase yesterday with Therese
coffee and today with Jacob Reese mogg
to blame other people just doesn't stick
in the end that shock to the system came
directly after the budget announcement
we've continued to see that instability
and it's a British problem it's not a
global problem it's a it's a problem for
British families who are paying much
higher mortgage costs and the government
needs to go back to the drawing board
start again properly fund their
commitment stop undermining the
independence of independent institutions
that help to bring calm and stability to
the markets and stop asking working
people to pay the price for a crisis
that they've created there isn't enough
money I think we all agree on that so
there isn't enough money for nurses paid
increases well there's a a whole set of
problems here the first is that we've
had a decade of very sluggish growth
we've had the slowest growth in the G7
post pandemic and that's a consequence
of not having invested which is part of
the reason why at our conference we set
our plans to invest in clean energy and
infrastructure and get this country
working again but we've also got this
problem of an economy that has been
crushed by the government so we've got
soaring inflation rates and that's
putting pressure on people's pay packets
as well the best way that you can deal
with this and the way that a labor
government would deal with this is to
scrap this mini budget properly fund and
cost all our commitments which we've
done but the government hasn't respect
the independence of Institutions like
the bank of England and the office for
Budget responsibility which are there to
bring stability and calm to the markets
and not push up the cost of borrowing
and and then go out and get money back
into people's pockets through good jobs
and wages but that's it that's the
that's the alternative that is off for
Britain right now and that's why yes
yesterday kirstylmer said he was putting
the labor party on an election footing
not because there's a lot at stake for
labor but because there's so much at
stake for the country I want to ask you
about the election in just a second but
you know the mini budget is about 45
billion we're already 60 billion in the
whole that's going to get even worse
there's no more money for pay Rises well
the part of the reason there's no money
for pay Rises is because the cost of
borrowing has gone up and the government
is now spending more to service debt
that's why we've said the first thing
that they've got to do before they make
any other commitments is go back to the
drawing board scrap this mini budget and
start again and properly fund and cost
their commitments that's what we're
going to do we haven't gone out making
commitments that this country can't
afford because it's people's money they
haven't got a lot of it and we're going
to be careful with every single penny
and would there be enough for pay Rises
for nurses well I've been absolutely
clear with you on this show before and
I'll continue to be clear that this
country needs a pay rise and when we
clapped for nurses and carers during the
pandemic we meant it but what I'm not
going to do is sit in this studio and
try to conduct some kind of pay
negotiation the government hasn't opened
the books to us we don't know what the
state of the NHS finances are but I can
tell you that when we're in government
if people trust us to to take the reins
and to try and sort this mess out what
we'll do is sit down with our Workforce
and negotiate our way through this to
treat them as partners in British
Endeavor not as enemies to be attacked
and undermined what do you mean by an
election footing well we when kiss
number was first elected a couple of
years ago he said that the first task of
his Premiership was to make labor fit to
govern again and we did that we tackled
anti-Semitism we've dealt with a lot of
the internal problems in the party then
he said to us we've got to go out and be
retro people we're ready to govern with
a plan for Britain and that's what this
conference was all about setting out big
plans for clean energy homegrown energy
more security more money in people's
pockets what he said yesterday is we've
got to get on an election footing
because an election could come at any
time this is the most unstable
government that seen the mood in
Parliament amongstorey MPS is pretty
mutinous we have no idea when a general
election is going to come but it could
come at any moment and we've got to be
ready because there's so much at stake
for this country happy Bonkers to call
an election night I mean you know I I
would suggest you that there would be
Bonkers to announce 43 billion pounds
worth of unfunded spending commitments
and refused to publish an independent
impact assessment of that and then
double down over the course of their
conference series of u-turns but
doubling down on the idea that you can
just keep spending money you don't have
so I genuinely I think this government
could do anything at any moment it's the
most unstable government I think of my
lifetime and so we've got to be ready
uh let me take you back to the governor
of the bank of England and what he has
been saying we've heard both from
quasiquarting and indeed from the Prime
Minister during the uh election campaign
for the leader they were both critical
of Andrew Bailey
um when we had Ruth Morgan um a little
bit earlier he was tiptoeing through the
raindrops what does labor think about it
I'm not going to criticize the governor
of the bank of England because we've
seen what happens when you attack and
undermine the independence of
Institutions that are independent for a
reason they're there to provide calm and
stability and what we've seen in the
last few weeks is the extraordinary
spectacle of the bank of England having
to step in three times to deal with a
government that has crashed the economy
and manufactured a crisis that working
people are paying for what the governor
of the bank of England is clearly trying
to do is bring some calm and stability
back to the market and to shore up the
bond market so that we don't see Pension
funds collapsing he needs to be given
space to get on with that but what we
most need to see is a government that
recognizes the mess that they've made
goes back to the drawing board and
starts again he says he's had lots of
sleepless nights of late Andrew Bailey
what about you
um a lot yeah I mean a couple of reasons
why one is that posts the budget my
office like most MPS offices was flooded
with people particularly mortgage payers
people saying the housing costs going up
as well as the food as well as their
energy prices and just not knowing how
they're going to survive this winter but
also because I know how much is at stake
that we have got to go out and show
people that we can be trusted to govern
again I think people are starting to
believe that again I would never have
thought that three years ago when we had
our worst election defeat in 100 years
but there's so much at stake for this
country and we've got to go out and make
sure that we we offer the change that is
needed your leader will be at the
dispatch box I'm guessing a little bit
later on facing Liz truss one wonders um
what um tack he might adopt might he
mentioned the Arsenal again in his
speech I have absolutely no idea what
he's going to do today what I do know is
that he's he's really concerned about
what happening to families up and down
this country and the biggest thing that
we want the government to do is to scrap
this mini budget and go back to the
drawing board so I suspect you'll see a
lot of that from Kirsten later but I
suspect as well that you might see quite
a bit of it from the Tory bat benches
we'll see thank you have you got any
intel on that and well just that I've
been in Parliament for yesterday after
the conference recess and I think there
is a very somber mood amongst
conservative MPS particularly you know
you've got the Richie soon act
supporters who feel very much like a
party within a party at the moment
they're very unhappy about the direction
of travel they don't seem to know what
to do about it we'll be calling on Tory
MPS to really stand up for the interests
of the country we all know that they've
got to scrap this mini budget we know
that they've got to start again we know
they've got to deal with working people
shouldering most of the costs for those
decisions and I hope that we can
persuade a lot of those story MPS to
stand up for the interests of Britain
and do the right thing okay it's good to
see you as always listen Andy thank you
very much indeed thanks